die schweiz ein land in dem man gerne
lebt ein land in dem eigentlich alles
funktioniert viele menschen tragen im
hintergrund dazu bei
kurt fischer effekt kamine im mittelland
valentin andré produziert biowein im
wallis alex kowal steuert dampfschiffe
über den genfersee
und berlioz betreut kinder in einem
zürcher hort wie leben diese menschen
wofür setzen sie sich ein
und was beschäftigt sie vier menschen
und ihr alltag ein tag im leben der
schweiz
[Musik]
fünf uhr morgens im kanton aargau
kaminfeger meister kurt ist eigentlich
kein morgenmuffel
[Musik]
na ja im kanton wallis eine stunde
später
winzerin valentina wird den tag draußen
verbringen
erst mal einen kaffee dann schaue ich
auch das wetter sie sagen regen voraus
mit ein bisschen sonne kurzes thema erst
in der werkstatt früh am morgen kann
sich der aargauer ganz ungestört seinen
morgenritual widmen
[Musik]
jene grundstücke und chaotisch
sehr wichtig
das ist
ich wünschte irgendwie besser wenn schon
gemacht
7 nur in mode aero zwischen lausanne und
genf
schiffskapitän alex ist franzose lebt
jedoch mit seiner frau und seinem sohn
in der schweiz
[Musik]
am morgen ist es immer eng für die ganze
familie
es ist ein kleines rennen buchstäblich
und ich mir betragen
und da ich heute morgen joggen werden
stehe ich ein wenig früher auf in
europas will instruiert kurz seine
belegschaft er ist von der gemeinde
gewählt und für die ganze region
zuständig kurz beschäftigt fünf männer
und vier frauen zwei davon als lehrlinge
vor 21 jahren hat sich der 53 jährige
selbstständig gemacht
china coal mine nachfrage also im hermes
zweite und voreinander noch ins tal hin
dass zur gleichen zeit im wallis
winzerin waren thema bewohnt in ihrem
großen weinkeller eine kleine
zweizimmerwohnung
es ist ein altes haus zuerst hatte ich
angst weil es so viele türen hat den
keller unten auf der anderen seite noch
zwei keller
es ist sehr groß aber ich habe nicht
daran gewöhnt sie arbeitet vor allem
alleine und stellt je nach saison
arbeitskräfte tageweise an
heute muss sie eine mitarbeiterin in
riedl abholen
im moment ist es etwas ruhiger
die reben liegen zwei bis drei wochen
hinter dem vorjahr zurück es ist ein
spätes jahr
wir haben den schnitt beendet wir haben
die triebe gesäubert jetzt kümmern wir
uns ein wenig um den boden das hat er
noch nie angetan
ich verstehe nichts davon ich frage
antonio aber eher ein überbrückungskabel
hat in muro im kanton waadt ist das
viertel vor sieben
alex ist in zweiter ehe mit sylvie
verheiratet die gebürtige waliserin
arbeitet 80 prozent die personalwesen
die beiden teilen sich die
familienarbeit auf fürs wecken ist alex
zuständig marta ist ein großes glück
unter der scheidung von seiner ersten
frau hat alles sehr gelitten
seine 15-jährige tochter sieht er nur
alle zwei wochen
sie ist mit ihrer mutter in frankreich
geblieben trinkt vorsichtig
während ziel wie martha zu ihren eltern
bringt macht sich alex fürst joggen
bereit
ich fahre bis neo und laufe danach geht
das sind ungefähr 20 km
[Musik]
es ist halb acht um diese zeit sind die
meisten menschen in der schweiz schon an
der arbeit
in stäfa am zürichsee lebt berlin mit
ihrem partner zusammen
[Musik]
sie ist sozialpädagogin und hort
leiterin und muss erst um 10 in zürich
sein
sie kann sich zeit lassen und macht
jeden morgen zehn minuten meditation
eigentlich extrem ist merkt man sich
zurückziehe
die langsamkeit ihnen und ich das einmal
gemacht links mal wieder öfter auf das
kühlt rücktritt
valentina steckt immer noch in räte fest
vielen dank wir sind gerettet männer
sind einfach wunderbar valentina die
gebürtige rumänin kam aber nicht wegen
eines mannes in die schweiz sondern um
französisch zu lernen
sie war damals 20 und hat sich sofort
ins wallis verliebt ich liebe die berge
bäume und die natur materielles bedeutet
mir nicht viel schöne häuser und so das
sagt mir nichts
[Musik]
ich liebe die natur es fühlt sich
einfach gut an
es gibt mehr energie wenn ich diese
berge sehr wenn ich schöne blumen sehe
dann spüre ich etwas
halb neun am genfer see seit zehn jahren
trainiert alex fünfmal in der woche und
nimmt regelmäßig an bergmarathon style
gerade trainiert er für einen teil in
spanien
ja ich brauche das ich hoffe es hält an
die jahre vergehen werde bass alex liebt
die ruhe und ist gerne allein mit meiner
arbeit ist es sehr schwierig eine
teamsportart oder eine mit genauen
zeitplänen zu betreten
daher passt dieser sport wirklich gut zu
mir und meiner arbeit
normalerweise braucht er ungefähr zwei
stunden für die 20 kilometer von neo
nach genf
[Musik]
in rupperswil im kanton aargau ist kurt
heute mit seiner stift in marisa
unterwegs gemeinsam müssen sie ein
großes bauernhaus reinigen und marisa
muss für die abschlussprüfung üben
warum ist kurt eigentlich kaminfeger
geworden sie den spruch du wirst und der
hat immer ist immer gut
die us-bürger dass sich auch die dritte
klasse diesmal knast weil ich entweder
hast
marisa vorstellig und kontrollierte was
sie macht
da mache ich natürlich in zwei monaten
hat marisa ihre abschlussprüfungen
schlitz in der branche dar frau die
machen da sagen
und auch jetzt zb die der familie seite
ausleben mache ich kann mich da sind
anlagen installiert und dann muss die
anlage übrigens glück nicht
[Musik]
ja sie
m
aktien
da war ich es
hier war für den kurs
tusk lake welt es möglich muss sagen
eigentlich vorfreude in genf am schiff
steht alex hat etwas mehr als zwei
stunden gebraucht kein neuer rekord
heute
gut mit diesem gegenwind es war ein
bisschen alex ist einer von 120000
franzosen in der schweiz
er arbeitet seit bald 30 jahren bei der
genfer schifffahrtsgesellschaft jetzt
nehme ich eine gemütliche dusche nachher
machen wir das brot klar essen etwas
und eine viertelstunde vor dem
einsteigen sie ist die uniform an und
mache nochmals eine tour und schiff auf
schweizer seen fahren noch 17 raddampfer
seit bald 14 jahren arbeitet alex schon
auf das savoir immer noch mit der
gleichen begeisterung ein original ein
gutes instrument von 1914
seit einem jahrhundert benutzt man das
gleiche material in der schweiz
verkehren viele dampfschiffe die flotte
wird sogar wieder ausgebaut weil die
leute gerne skifahren in frankreich ist
ein wenig anders es gibt auch große
traditionen aber nicht diese und es war
nicht das was man mir hätte anbieten
können als ich 20 war ich werde sicher
in frankreich geblieben wenn ich diesen
job dort hätte machen können
kurz vor 10 im wallis valentina
bewirtschaftet seit fünf jahren
verschiedene raid berger auf 4 hektaren
rund ums ei sie hat sich zur winzerin
und weinhändlerin ausbilden lassen und
produziert biodynamischen wein heute 60
kg an so siehst du von einer seite die
dann machst du dasselbe von der anderen
seite wieder zurück ich habe den klee
gewählt weil er niedrig bleibt
ich versuche damit die pflanzen zu
unterdrücken die etwas zu hoch wachsen
und mit der rebe konkurrieren
zudem wird der boden so mit stickstoff
angereichert valentina ist immer noch
beeindruckt von der schweizer anbau
tradition in steilem gelände hier haben
wir vier linien mauer an mauer
ich komme aus rumänien wir haben
hektaren von verlassenen weil hier
kultiviert man jeden meter land das
finde ich unglaublich mit 35 hat sie
sich als bio wein produzentin bereits
einen namen gemacht woher kommt ihre
faszination für den weinbau von klein
auf habe ich meinen eltern in der
landwirtschaft geholfen die
landwirtschaftlichen grundsätze bleiben
die gleichen
auch wenn es tomaten sind wir hatten
auch einen weinberg in rumänien
ich liebte es trauben zu pflücken und
als ich in rumänien meinen abschluss
machte ging ich in den hängen trauben
es war großartig da war eine energie die
hat lust gemacht auf mehr
die hat etwas ausgelöst also du ziehst
es raus aber nicht zu verzerren
nur eine oberfläche es ist kurz vor zehn
am zürichsee berlin pendelt in einer
halben stunde muss sie anfangen
vor dem hard hat sie in jugendheimen
gearbeitet und statik und märkte
gestellt und das ist für mich
zudem liebt sie kinder
berlin ist selbst das tochter von
schweizern in uganda geboren und hat
immer wieder im ausland gelebt und
gearbeitet was schätzt sie besonders in
der schweiz
das ist er
seit neun jahren leitet sie einen hort
im zürcher multikulti quartier kreis
vier neue haben in der stadt zürich alle
kinder ein recht auf einen
betreuungsplatz über mittag die belegung
hat darum extrem zugenommen
im schulhaus wohl gehen 320 kinder zur
schule
zwei drittel davon werden im moment noch
in sechs verschiedenen horten betreut
wie gestalten wir die abläufe haben wir
haben eine gruppe zu besprechen und lage
am genfer see es ist 11 bevor der
ansturm losgeht trifft sich alex mit
seiner gut zum mittagessen
dieser moment ist uns heilig
die essenszeit mögen wir gerne wir
können uns ein bisschen ausruhen
wir können zusammen essen wir haben
lange tage und dieser kleiner unterbruch
finden wir toll
wir schätzen das sehr sie haben keinen
stress
jeder weiß was er zu tun hat einige von
uns kennen sich seit vielen jahren die
älteren unter uns sind schon lange hier
das funktioniert gut
koch vorbereitungen laufen auch im
kanton aargau kurth hat den mittagstisch
eingeführt jeder mitarbeiter hat eine
woche lang küchendienst bezahlte
arbeitszeit selbstverständlich
mittagstisches in der kommunikations
plattform wo extrem sind sieht regel
bewaffnet mit messer und gabel
und wenn ich mir gerade so am telefon
oder am computer so noch persönliche
sachen mitgenommen besprechen
das richtige bieten eigentlich dass in
der team- eine arbeitsstelle sei möglich
arbeitsweise und salz schön sie der chef
nutzt die zeit für ein bisschen
unterricht mit marisa sowie die höhere
der heizwert von holz
da ist super so sachen im hausacher
wunderbar verbinden so informationen wie
de oder informationen unterstützen so
zum beispiel tumore weltauto brief das
sei im schulhaus wohl in zürich leute
das mittagspause
aber natürlich verschiedene miranda
tsx-v mad sprechen finke gruppe und
unten ist so hat so langsam mit der
erste schweizer mit kind wo diskutiert
so gesehen und mittlerweile haben es auf
50 50 situation und das finde ich immer
mein tag ich sehr schön wenn's
profitieren alle in eurem gaga sich
vorgenommen
am anfang macht barrel immer ein kleines
gruppengespräch ausflug wo gehen wir hin
flug und hotel sind noch mit auf den
flug hat ist allerersten will muss die
zeit das viertel vereins überbrücken
wegen der hohen belegung müssen die
kinder in zwei etappen essen
mittagspause auch im wallis valentina
geht mit maria ins noble in seinem essen
das restaurant bezieht regelmäßig wein
von ihr
valentin hatte keine mühe sich hier im
wallis zu integrieren
ich glaube es ist auch weil die leute
gesehen haben hat es sich arbeiten als
ich 2013 14 angefangen habe habe ich
alles selbst gemacht den anbau die lese
sie haben mir wohl geholfen weil sie
gesehen haben dass ich alles mache ich
denke das ist das was zählt
essen ist fertig auch in rapperswil am
mittagstisch mit dabei ist auch immer
kurz ex frau rita die beiden haben das
geschäft gegründet und zusammen eine 23
jährige tochter als paar sind sie aber
schon lange getrennt
dass sie wie eine chefsekretärin liebe
tod und funktioniert einfach super
berlin das die kinder am liebsten
draußen herumtoben wenn sie aufs essen
warten müssen
was gefällt dir besonders an ihrer
arbeit
[Musik]
endlich ist viertel vor eins
heute gibt es doch ein spezielles
geburtstags ritual im moment dürfen die
kinder noch in gruppen essen/berlin fan
ist wichtig dass das auch so bleibt
[Musik]
zurück in genf
alex hat sich umgezogen
ein bisschen
für die menschen ist die uniform wichtig
sie hat tradition es wurde immer eine
strenge uniform getragen
es liegt auch an uns diese tradition zu
pflegen auch nach 30 dienstjahren ist da
immer noch stolz auf sein schiff
es ist ein teil der schweiz
die schiffe auf allen seen der schweiz
das ist etwas wichtiges und ihren farben
sie gehören einfach zur landschaft
es ist mutig sie schwimmen dort sieht er
das sagen auf einem boot muss man immer
vorsichtig sein
als kleiner junge waren die schiffe für
mich der inbegriff von abenteuer die
magie dieser schiffe hat mich
angesprochen
als ich das zum ersten mal gesehen habe
sagte ich mir ich fand sie so schön und
begann davon zu träumen
auf einem solchen schiff zu arbeiten
[Musik]
valentinus leidenschaft gilt nicht nur
ihrem weinberg sondern auch ihrem
weinkeller
während der lese kann ich nicht
einschlafen bevor ich nicht bei allen
fässern war und alles gut ist
manchmal komme ich sehr spät mitternacht
zwei uhr morgens aber ich muss die tour
machen
sie sind wie kinder wenn du dich nicht
um sie kümmern bevor du ins bett gehst
kannst du nicht schlafen
von diesem weißwein produziert valentina
nur gerade 1000 liter gelernt hat sie
bei der walliser wein ikone marie theres
schaper sie hat valentina vom
biodynamischen anbau überzeugt ich habe
es so gelernt und möchte so natürlichen
wein wie möglich produzieren ohne
einzugreifen wenn du gute trauben im
keller hass und wenn du gute böden hast
dann finde ich
soll man die erde machen lassen es ist
halb zwei
beryl hat nur wenige kinder am
nachmittag es bleibt zeit ihnen ihre
afrikanische vergangenheit ein bisschen
näher zu bringen und diese fehde das
land ruft waren konnten und von dort das
ist chance und auch die factory wurde
sind das auch für gekochtes kopieren zu
machen wenn ihr unterwegs um reise und
sogar unter natürlichen 1 gemacht und
das warum und wieso ob ich ihn auf krieg
und ist wirklich so dass die taufe
geboren unterbieten und da habe ich
einfach drucklos einfach nur einige
meter hohen einer wohnungs stunden aus
ihrer geschichte heraus hat sich lange
auch in einer schule in nairobi
engagiert wie hin zum teil stunde laufe
zur mitte wo am samstag und am sonntag
an urenco wo extrem hinweg wenn es dort
nicht und jeder dachte gleich polizei
will würde das überzählige essen aus dem
hort gerne an bedürftige im quartier
verteilen
aber das darf sie nicht die steilen der
schweizer hat sie immer wird es auch so
schwierig gestoßen
tja und wenn er an das ist ganz anders
läuft und es funktioniert und wie man
merke ich glaube es hat so nimmt der
mensch als auch jede regierung um zum
gps gesteuert machen wie möglich
sehr viel internist 1000 was ist also
immer auch zum teil ii sa
unsere perspektive oder zur wartung
lieber wäre
kurt ist auf dem weg zur berufsschule
olten um einen schulbesuch bei seinem
erstliga stift zu machen
[Musik]
er wollte nie weg von hier und kennt die
gegend wie seine eigene hosentasche
sogar mit julia wagen flur wasser so
dass ich so was ist das verbindet des
kurth nimmt seine aufgabe als
lehrmeister sehr ernst und gibt
ebenfalls kurse hier 40 kaminfeger und
kamin pflegerinnen werden allein an der
berufsschule olten ausgebildet
gesamtschweizerisch sind es 192
alex ist schon zwei stunden unterwegs er
macht zwei bis drei fahrten pro tage bei
den zweitgrößten see mitteleuropas
so kommt der tägliche auch auf die
französische seite in seine alte heimat
was hält der franzose von den schweizern
die schweizer sind sehr offen für das
was im ausland geschieht aber ich glaube
sie hängen auch sehr an ihrem land so
sehe ich es sie würden ja landet alles
in der welt verteidigen und hängen sehr
an ihren traditionen und an ihrer heimat
all die kleinen sachen der schweiz
ausmachen
die darf man nicht antasten
matuschek und die genfer
schifffahrtsgesellschaft transportierte
2017 fast 23 millionen passagiere
und es werden jedes jahr mehr manche
passagiere nehmen sich zeit stellen
fragen machen fotos usw
das tiger kreuzfahrt
[Musik]
alles daran sich selbstständig zu machen
in diesem gebäude bietet coaching an die
drei frauen haben zusammen die
ausbildung gemacht und treffen sich
regelmäßig zum feedback berlin möchte
sich auf einzelne kinder und ihre eltern
konzentrieren
ein angebot das es so bisher außerhalb
von turin kaum gibt
unabhängig von dem schulsystem läuft
sie ist erst am anfang könnte sich aber
durchaus vorstellen ihr konzept mit dem
zu ergänzen was ihr selbst wichtig ist
im leben
die leserschaft der garten und natur und
coaching
das kam mir die idee in der natur koffer
mit beliebt
valentina ist auf dem weg zu einer
speziellen weindegustation sie
produziert wenig aber teuren wein
neben ihr gibt es rund 33.000
weinproduzenten in der schweiz
circa eine million hektoliter wein
werden jährlich produziert ist der markt
nicht schon gesättigt
ich glaube nicht dass er gesättigt ist
ich denke wir müssen gute weine machen
da ist platz für alle manchmal finde ich
dass wir uns hier in der schweiz
gegenseitig zu fest kritisieren
einerseits unter den kantonen aber auch
unter den produzenten
es gibt doch platz für alle die
schweizer rockband gotthard gibt ein
konzert in lausanne
die musiker haben valentina und den
bekannten tessiner winzer sascha pelosi
beauftragt für sie einen neuen wein zu
kreieren zusammengebracht hat sie nicola
wüst der freund von valentina er ist
weinliebhaber und hans dampf in allen
gassen
die bandmitglieder haben eine vorliebe
für guten wein und treffen sich
regelmäßig
wir haben einen wein club im tessin 43
mit unseren freunden dass banker
darunter gastronomen
wir machen immer abend der mit lindt
installationen wissen nicht was dahinter
steckt wir haben die themen und es gibt
gewinner jeder bringt seine beste
flaschen mit es ist halt selig halb wein
lieben drei verschiedene varianten mit
unterschiedlichen missverhältnis stehen
zur auswahl
leo leoni nick meter und freddy schenk
sind sich jedoch schnell einig er ist
ein bisschen fruchtiger wunder wenn wir
noch ein jahr warten kommt der zweite
sicher nicht es ist 8
alex versucht in der vor saison
möglichst früh nach hause zu kommen
seine familie und sein zuhause sind
ihnen das wichtigste
[Musik]
wenn ich nach hause komme und er mich
hört dann wartet er schon auf mich der
kleine kerl wenn ich nicht zu spät bin
recht ist noch um zusammen zu essen
das genieße ich sehr denn im sommer in
der hochsaison wird das nicht mehr
möglich sein
im sommer ist sehen wir uns viel weniger
manchmal kommt es vor dass ich den
kleinen eine ganze woche nicht sehen
weil er schon im bett ist halb neun bei
berlin zu hause
sie ist angekommen auch im übertragenen
sinne landschaft nur gemeint ich merke
immer mehr wurde vor drei jahren konnten
sie und ihr frauen dieses haus mit
garten mieten
philipp ist lehrer aber die beiden
verbindet nicht nur berufliches sondern
auch die liebe zur natur
[Musik]
seit 15 stunden ist kurz fischer heute
schon unterwegs aber für ihn ist immer
noch nicht feierabend
seit jahren engagiert er sich im
vorstand des lokalen gewerbevereins ist
vom tisch nachdem das ist die diskussion
müsse was bringt das wenn der hund der
grund der optoma rektor einer die
vorstandsmitglieder sind alte freunde
code findet es wichtig dass man sich
freiwillig engagiert betrieben ist dann
mache ich einfach mit das ist so üblich
dass die lehrlingsausbildung gar nicht
nützlich machen was immer wieder welche
zukünftig und organisiere und ein
anderes leben und zukunft
die traktanden sind schnell abgearbeitet
zeit für den gemütlichen teil des abends
kurz freuen die die regular stößt dazu
die beiden sind seit elf jahren ein paar
[Musik]
rolle
ein plättchen in einer kleinen runde von
freunden kommt immer gut an
[Musik]
280 km entfernt in motor ist es zeit für
ins bett
[Musik]
alex und sylvie machen auch das
gemeinsam sie sind ein gutes team
[Musik]
in meinem leben werde ich meine frau
nicht wechseln und ich werde auch meine
job nicht wechseln e mail songschreiber
treibern opel
ich realisiere langsam dass ich mir auch
wieder mehr zeit für mich selbst nehmen
kann
[Musik]
im großen und ganzen habe ich also einen
job der mir gefällt
ich habe eine familie mit der ich
glücklich bin
es geht mir gut und ich habe meine
kleinen aktivität das alles zusammen
gibt dann das gleichgewicht
ich liebe das leben das ich habe ich
würde nichts ändern
[Musik]
im metropol in lausanne hat das konzert
von gott hat begonnen
valentin und nicola sind seit einem jahr
zusammen
zwei die ihre leidenschaft leben haben
sich gefunden
ich habe nicht viel zeit und nicola
arbeitet auch viel dass er einen dichten
terminplan hat passt ich könnte nicht
mit jemandem zusammen sein der bis 5 im
büro arbeitet ich wäre dann auch
gezwungen ein normales leben zu führen
[Musik]
für kurt war es ein langer tag
vor sieben jahren haben sich regula und
er das haus in veltheim gekauft die
unfallchirurgen und der kaminfeger haben
sich in einer klinik in aarau kennen und
lieben gelernt
mit dem betrieb von skifahren als ein
bis zwei solcher geschäfte skifahren und
großer bus fahren und halt die zeit
tatsächlich glauben in den unfalls
machen werde schlussendlich horizontal
wie die rucola fürs grüne tod wir haben
ihn ja so ist kein erklärt prozent macht
sehr gut
[Musik]
auch berlin und philipp haben es sich
gemütlich eingerichtet
eine sache gibt es jedoch die sie
bedrückt sie wünschen sich schon lange
ein kind aber bisher hat es noch nicht
geklappt und das ist viel zu fliegen und
frust und als das ist alles aus und
ließen das ist noch nicht klar wie
wiederum ein leben lang immer
irgendwelche und und mary mac seit wann
es wenn es geht nicht dass das geschenk
und dann ist das schön und wenn es
manchmal nicht dann ist eine besonders
bestimmt und vor dem ruhrgebiet auf
jeden fall weiß ich dass ich mit der
familie und mit dem hof zurück
[Gelächter]
ein tag im leben der schweiz geht zu
ende valentina und nicola sind auf dem
heimweg
morgen stehen sie wieder auf und mit
ihnen mehr als acht millionen andere
menschen in der schweiz jeder mit seinem
alltag um mit seiner geschichte nächste
woche klar die blanke fällt bäume im
energien ritter streulicht kontrolliert
billette bei den zürcher
verkehrsbetriebe hansjörg schweizer
markiert signalisationen auf appenzell
straßen und sabina führt einen zoo im
tessin